Gmail Tap revolutionizes the way we speak to each other because...
...whereas with the QWERTY keyboard, which was invented in 1878,...
...you have all these letters, these 26 letters jammed into this two-and-a-half-inch space,...
...now you just have two buttons, you have a dot and a dash.
All you have to do is this.
It's amazing.
You can tap it in the morning.
You can tap it in the kitchen, you can tap it at night.
You can tap it in the bathroom.
You can tap it on a seesaw.
Technology is everywhere these days.
Everyone has a smartphone.
The phone may be smart but the keyboard is dumb.
In a station wagon, a wheelbarrow, you could, I mean, it's incredible.
You can tap it in a movie theater.
You can tap it in the hallway.
I mean it's just all of these things at once.
It's amazing.
It's IM to the next level.